Nikola Tesla passed away on January 7th
1943 at his hotel room at the New Yorker
and two days later the FBI conducted a
raid and took possession of all of his
belongings including nearly 80 trunks or
two full truckloads of handwritten
paperwork in this video I'm going to
connect the dots on key pieces of
evidence that will convince any
reasonable person that not only are we
looking at a real-life genuine
conspiracy but the allegations evolving
a cover-up on behalf of the FBI
following the events of Nikola Tesla's
death is not only real but it also
involved the CIA and I have the
documentation to prove this now if
you're not familiar with Nikola Tesla as
most people are not especially in the
United States as he's not even required
learning in the public school system
despite the fact that eighty percent of
all of our modern technology is based
off his inventions works in achievement
in fact we're talking about the person
who invented the technology to harness
the AC current which is of course
utilized to power the entire electrical
grid throughout the modern world not
only that the Tesla invented the
electrical motor which is used in so
many different aspects of our lives and
here I just threw up a few photos of
some ideas that I thought of but there
are many other examples it's incredible
Tesla also invented the remote control
what she demonstrated in front of
shocked crowds more than a hundred years
ago and is the result of so much
convenience in our daily lives that we
take for granted we don't think about
too often another little known fact is
that Tesla invented the radio not
Marconi in fact the Supreme Court ruled
on this decades ago but most people are
not aware of this Tesla had hundreds of
patents throughout the world in fact
inventions such as the television
computers lasers x-rays robotics and
many other things can be credited at
their roots based on the works and
achievements that Tesla had completed
Tesla had also claimed that he had
perfected the technology to harness
wireless free energy to the entire world
and he even began works on completing
this technology which referred to as a
Tesla tower until GP Morgan one of the
heirs to the banking conglomerate which
is a whole different story
pullback funding and gave it to Thomas
Edison who we'll get to in just a second
but Tesla was so adamant that he had
pleaded and perfected this ability that
he wrote 50 letters over five years to
JPMorgan begging and pleading that
listen I just need more funding I have
perfected this technology but JPMorgan
did not go along with it
and ultimately he demolished the site
and this is what's left of it you know
it's interesting many people don't
believe that Tesla had perfected that
technology but why would you doubt him I
mean you certainly believe in Wi-Fi you
believe in satellite TV or radio which
when you think about it we're talking
about energy and information coming out
of thin air and it's really incredible
when you think about it now Tesla is the
same person who accurately and epically
I should say describes a cell phone or
even the Skype and FaceTime apps or
Smart TVs for that matter back in 1926
in fact take a second to pause the video
and read this quote but people called
Tesla crazy or a mad scientist for this
they never believed it and all of these
things tie into a Tesla had stated about
understanding the secrets of the
universe would require to think in terms
of energy frequency and vibration which
is of course what these things are so a
Nikola Tesla stated adamantly a month
before his death that he had perfected
the death ray which would essentially
just make planes fall out of the sky you
have to start to wonder had he figured
that out now going back to Thomas Edison
most people think that he invented the
lightbulb which he did not in fact
mainstream outlets around the world are
starting to report on this in just the
last few years yet they still teach us
in the public schooling system it's
ridiculous all Edison did was buy the
patent and he had a few dozen interns
perfected and then he stamped his name
on it and made a fortune in the process
in fact Edison was not an inventor he
hardly invented anything in fact he
actually screwed over Nikola Tesla when
he refused to pay him a promised $50,000
which would be equivalent to a few
million dollars today when Nikola Tesla
perfected the AC current over the DC
current which was what Thomas Edison was
pushing all around the world in fact
Thomas Edison if you want to know what
kind of person he was
he literally electrocuted dogs horses
and elephants to try and discredit the
AC current in order to prop up the DC
current saying that it was much safer
which just wasn't true whatsoever in
fact that reminds me do you wanna know
something that Edison actually did
invent the electric chair that's right
he sold the electric chair and profited
off a
invention that would kill people she had
to ask yourself somebody who profited
off electrocuting animals and people why
is it that we're being taught so many
great things about him in school when
the true narrative about this guy is
just being kept in the dark now with all
of that said let me transition into the
cover-up and conspiracy so four decades
after the FBI raided Nikola Tesla's
hotel room and took possession of all of
his paperwork and other belongings they
claimed that they immediately handed
over to the office of alien property
custodian which was odd by the way
because Nikola Tesla had already been a
US citizen for more than 50 years but
ultimately this was in the heart of
World War Two and he wanted to make sure
that there was nothing within his
possession that could be well the
information can be utilized by the enemy
but what's odd is that the government
actually held on to all of his
possessions for nine years
not until 1952 is when they finally
release all of his possessions and
paperwork back over to his family
overseas in Belgrade so in 2013 the FBI
was required to release documentation on
Nikola Tesla following a request filed
through the Freedom of Information Act
and you can actually see these documents
online through the FBI's website but
these declassified documents caught the
FBI red-handed in multiple lives in fact
the FBI was interviewed in 2008 by
wired.com in order to discuss the 10
greatest myths ever about the FBI and
number 10 was get this about them having
Nikola Tesla's plans for a death ray let
me read to you and I quote despite
long-standing reports and rumors the FBI
was not involved in searching Tesla's
effects and never had possession of his
papers or any microfilm that may have
been made of those papers since 1943 we
have told a consistent story to all who
have asked reports to the contrary
appear to be based on an initial
confusion of FBI agents with other
government officials especially alien
Property Office personnel these rumors
have been repeated in biographies and
articles on Tesla without
double-checking the facts as reported in
our files but when these files were
Declassified five years later Willa
caught them in more than one lie now
before I show you those documents is one
really important aspect of this case and
it's really odd so professor John G
Trump who worked at MIT was the
person chosen to review all of Tesla's
documents and in less than three days
after Nikola Tesla's property was
confiscated by the FBI and handed over
to the office of alien custodian John G
Trump announced to the world that no
there was nothing significant in these
files and that ultimately did not
contain any plans of anything of
significant in fact I quote Tesla's
thoughts and efforts during at least the
last 15 years were primarily of
speculative philosophical and somewhat
promotional character often concerned
with the production and wireless
transmission of power but did not
include new sound workable principles or
methods for realizing such results yet
when you look at this declassified
documents to the director of the FBI it
specifically states that we believe that
certain of Tesla's papers may contain
basic principles which would be of
considerable value to certain ongoing
research within the DoD the Department
of Defense it would be truly helpful to
have access to his papers but besides
that the declassified documents from the
FBI literally discussed that a low Tesla
wrote in English his penmanship was
small blurred and so difficult to
translate as a foreign language and in
these same documents in fact multiple
documents state that the FBI did have
microfilm so essentially they took
photos copies of every single one of
Tesla's documents so when they stated
for decades that no we don't have
Tesla's paperwork now okay yeah you they
didn't have his paperwork but they had
copies of it so they deliberately
manipulated their words in order to
convince those that were asking that no
we don't have anything on him which was
a direct omission of truth which is
interesting I mean the FBI I mean there
are officers of the court and in court
if you omit the truth well that's a
perjury that's a felony but to make
everything even more suspicious out of
more than 300 documents that were
released by the FBI a significant amount
of them have overwhelming redactions on
these papers to the point you can't even
read them and although most of the
papers are just blank and you can read
them on your own on an unbelievable
amount of them have significant
redactions I mean look at these Sharpie
oaths you can even read this stuff like
what does it say and why is it being
left out seventy-three years later after
his death but if you want another
indicator of dishonest behavior on
behalf of the
see I the very last document they have a
Nikola Tesla before he died was back in
September of 1940 which was a memo
written to the director of the FBI
j.edgar hoover suggesting that they put
24/7 or constant surveillance on Nikola
Tesla without his knowing in order to
prevent him from being kidnapped by the
enemy and essentially being tortured for
information involving his technologies
and inventions and then after this
there's not a single documents for two
and a half years later until his death
in 1943 so despite the fact that the FBI
has dozens and dozens of correspondence
and documentation related to Nikola
Tesla before his death
that FBI director gets a suggestion that
he put on surveillance on Tesla and
there's nothing after that
not a yes that says the surveillance not
a no not a maybe nothing do they really
expect us to believe that does that make
any sense that it wouldn't even warrant
a reply whatsoever I mean do you believe
that I don't so here's the part about
the CIA so you might remember two days
before President Obama left office in
January of 2017
he Declassified nearly 13 million
documents from the CIA which made
headlines all around the world because
they discussed various things such as
psychic abilities UFOs even CIA torture
practices on detainees and terrorists
but one thing that was just not
mentioned and I have not seen anything
online internet forums YouTube that
discuss the fact that Nikola Tesla is
also contained in those files I took it
upon myself to literally just type in
and anyone can do this by the way good
CIA gov click on the Freedom of
Information Act and type in Nikola Tesla
which is what I did and why I was
shocked to see that yeah they have
several documents on him now besides the
fact that there are redactions
blacked-out marks or even more
pretty-looking whiteout marks as you can
see here these documents indicate that
they had a secret investigation into
Nikola Tesla sites overseas they had
inventories they took names and I mean
who knows what else they left out but
there's clearly missing documents here
as well I mean where's the documents
leading up to this investigation where's
the documents at the end of the
investigation but here's the one thing
that sticks out so many people were
wondering why it took the government
nine years to release Tesla's property
to his family
well these documents from the CIA
indicate that the concluded their
investigation in 1952 which just so
happens to be the very same year the
nikola tesla's property was handed back
over to his family in belgrade do you
really think this has just a coincidence
so in other words this explains what
they were doing they were conducting an
investigation on who knows what
involving his facilities for who knows
what reasons but it shows this and
nobody's aware of this the CIA which
wasn't even created for four years after
Tesla died was conducting an
investigation on him in his overseas
facilities why is that so when you
connect the dots and everything I've
discussed the FBI lying over seven
decades about Nikola Tesla the fact that
they did have copies of his
documentation and they manipulated the
wording in order to confuse others and
essentially tell a lie the fact that
they have all these redaction
73 years after his death the fact that
the CIA was doing a secret investigation
on Tesla and that the government just so
happens to release all this
documentation on the precise time frame
and year that the CIA concluded that
investigation and then you have Nikola
Tesla somebody that's known to have
outstanding character they wanted to
help humanity the died poor and has been
shunned by the mainstream and our
academics which is pretty weird don't
you think when you had all these things
together and the fact that he was
adamant that he had created the ability
the technology to harness free
technology for the entire world or free
energy I should say wireless energy or
the death ray and many other things when
you add all these things together and
you look at the behavior on behalf of
the government well guys what are you
left with
it's beyond obvious that there is
absolutely a cover-up here they have
some sort of technology of you know that
Tesla had I mean I would even be
surprised if you look up the what's
called the Active Denial system or the
heat gun I wouldn't be surprised if
that's based on Tesla's a technology
referring to the death rate may be
different obviously but look where does
it go from here bottom line is that the
government clearly still has
documentation on Tesla the CIA files and
the FBI files both indicate that they
have not released everything I mean
think about it the FBI director J Edgar
Hoover receives a memo suggesting they
put constant surveillance on him and
then for two and a half years later
there's not a single
try to correspondence on em all together
give me a break
hopefully there's some up-and-coming
hungry lawyer that's familiar with the
Freedom of Information Act that looks
over this information and decides to
make a name for themselves anyways guys
I'll leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe leave me a comment let me
know what your thoughts are and I'll
also include a link for my other videos
on Nikola Tesla as well take care
everybody